che è sta roba ma si può uscire
bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono
oggi iniziamo la serie sul won the
grudge allora premetto che io ho visto
il figlio ho visto la l'intera saga del
film di john li ho visti tutti e tre
e tra tutti i film horror che ho visto
in generale del graggio è stato la sagra
in generale di degrado è stata quella
che mi ha inquietato veramente forse è
quella che mi ha inquietato di più di
tutti
quindi dato che il film mi ha fatto così
paura non vedeva appunto l'ora di poter
giocare al videogame
quindi grazie veramente per avermelo
consigliato così posso morire felice
allora test e del coraggio ma loro sanno
chi stanno parlando qui io il coraggio
me lo mangio a colazione scegli il tuo
sesso maschio
scegli il tuo segno zodiacale ariete
perfetto devo darti anche il codice
fiscale no perfetto andiamo
niente devo che cos'è sta roba fabbrica
desolata iniziamo vai così vai così
caricamento sono prontissimo
c'è un bello fu che doveva dove vai qui
dove vai
hanno usato qualcosa ha pensato una
merda ma veramente lui che la lascia la
merda magari poi la penso io non sa dove
sta andando
perché allora no non andare lì fu fino
ad andare lì fu fino nanda ok
esistono le scarpe esistono le scarpe
made by comunque a scalzo va bene o no
quella evin o si chiama fufi che ivi
scappare via in quel modo ma cosa avrà
mai visto questa fabbrica sembra
abbandonata da sempre bene se non torna
da sola è meglio che vada a cercarla ma
giustamente andiamo in una fabbrica
abbandonata
erika ho scelto che ho messo che sono
maschio e mi chiamo erika bacheca scusa
se mettiamo femmina mi chiamavo ungono
ha capito cosa sta facendo
dove siamo la gara inizia malissimo
cos'è sto posto ok no no no che cazzo è
successo si è chiusa la porta si è
chiusa la madonna ragazzi iniziamo male
se chiusa la porta e non possiamo più
uscire perfetto se stai calma stai calma
sei tu l'idiota che vice i posti per
trovare un cane cosa vuoi
se sei tu l'idiota che va in sti posti
per cercare i cani poi ti lamenti anche
quando succedono ste cose perché
succedono
ok raga posso muovermi bene siamo
ricapitolando in una stanza chiusi non
possiamo uscire però rilancia una porta
quindi andiamo su vedo qualcosa che
luccica
c'è 5 cosa che luccica sulla sedia
laggiù vabbè poi ci vado comunque siamo
liberi finalmente finalmente un paio di
palle ma vabbè nella cee fufi c'è già
fulvio trovato l'ho trovato mai buffet
profitto ha trovato no che cazzo
successo ma che cazzo successi chi la
porta chiusa il vento
porca [ __ ] ok
salve prof cazzo bene
c'era un bambino l'ho visto dove si è
chiuso la porta e se non posso più
salvare fufi fufi resisti c'è girati che
c'è un cazzo di bambino l'iva non vorrei
che di nuovo su ok
ci siamo dov'è andato non è caccia
andato fufi ma era lì prima come può
andar via un cane i mortacci sua sta
cazzo di luce
vabbè apro anche questo ma dove cazzo
andato fu non è che cioè non so capita
questa raga però va beh
vabò apriamo anche st porta all anzi
ogni volta che apro le porte raga perché
deve aprirle così
ok andiamo avanti porca [ __ ] bolcato
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no se ok
vai sì o c'è calmi calmi calmi quasi mi
mista il cavo sta prendendo possesso del
mio corpo tra l'altro
bene come cazzo faccio adesso
posso aprire la porta tranquillo mi devo
aspettare di nuovo sta cosa anche se
comunque non ci entrerei lo stesso in
sostanza ma vabbè
ok avere sparito che cazzo era bene
almeno è sparita almeno questo dove
cazzo siamo
cos'è sta roba ski
ringrazio iddio che la visuale non sale
fino a un certo punto perché veramente
non voglio sapere che cosa sta
gocciolando dal soffitto
spero che non sia fufi ho sentito un
rumore
ho sentito un rumore non mi è piaciuto
ho sentito il rumore che non mi è
piaciuto ma penso che sia bambino che
corre nudo vabbè porca [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] ragazzi mi è venuto
io quando mi sparo e ragga quanto quando
mi spavento rido sempre ma quando mi
spavento veramente tanto non la voleva
dire che cazzo è crollata è crollato
[ __ ] ha tirato un calcio ho tirato
un calcio en scrivania porca [ __ ] che
mai
vabbè lasciamo stare andiamo via andiamo
via andiamo via perfetto c'è qualcosa
che luccica io mi devo allontanare da
questo maledetto posto prima che succeda
qualcos'altro che cazzo è crollato
è crollato dal soffitto bene andiamo
andiamo avanti non curanti di cosa cade
dal soffitto
raga chi ha fatto sto gioco veramente
merita l'ergastolo però non mi importa
c'è un'altra cosa che luccica un'altra
chiave perfetto perfetto è caduta un è
caduto un casco o accaduto cos'era un
casco cadero ragazza d'europa dal
soffitto non capisco che cazzo succede
cos'è cos'è accaduto tra l'altro un
casco che ha eccolo cos'è boh boh io in
cad è roba che è buono mi spiego ove c'è
della roba che luccica sul soffitto ma
penso sia una lucciola soltanto non
importa non voglio saperlo andiamo via
di qua che brutto posto
chi me l'ha fatto fare di entrare qui
dentro non lo so non c'è più niente
verona perfetto veramente ragazze andare
a cercare un cane cioè almeno in questo
videogame diversamente dagli altri oro
si capisce perché ci siamo ritrovati in
questo posto
vabbè entriamo in sa porta ovviamente
ok ok non me l'aspettavo mi aspettavo di
tutto però non è successo niente
cazzo siano bene va bene siamo in una
stanza non identificata anche questa
però va beh cerco di madonna quanto vai
lento anche tu
cerco di non so neanche cosa devo fare
perché il cane è sparito non sono che
cosa sto facendo in questo gesto ancora
cercando il cane non penso perché a sto
punto c'è cos'è sta roba
vedo qualcosa all'interno è chiusa si
vabbè qua intanto è pieno di caschi
estintori un'altra un'altra pila
un'altra pila le pile sono utilissime
perché non oso pensare che cosa succede
se rimango senza non lo vogliono anche
scoprire bene prima di salire per ho
visto qualcosa che luccicava nel retro
scala quindi devo andare di dietro altri
di un altro lido luminoso intanto
bene certo se starà male l'altra pila
prefetto che schifo ma che schifo ma che
cazzo se li è mangiati
scommetto che è stato il bambino
batteria di viserba perfetto che schifo
è ma dai ragazzi ma che cazzo è un piano
ok c'è qualcuno io mi sto facendo
malissimo sto continuare a tirare calci
alla scrivania distinto è il mio piede
sta chiedendo pietà meglio che stia
fermo veramente c'è un male c'è un male
assurdo vabbè andiamo su
bene cioè che schifo un altro ma che
merda la gamma bova beh lasciamo stare
ho trovato una pila quindi devo andare
piano di sopra
mi sembrava di aver visto una faccia
attraverso la finestra non lo so girate
piano di sopra ragazzi piano di sopra
ok ce la puoi fare mammamia sembri mia
nonna salire le scale
no veramente raga lo fa con una lentezza
spropositata vabbè lasciamo perdere c'è
c'è cos'è questa l'uscita perché c'è un
segnale di uscita su aversi ovviamente
l'uscita dall altra parte ma noi
addentriamoci c'è una porta vagamente
vagamente invitante che cazzo è che è
sta roba
ma si può uscire porca [ __ ]
maledetti stronzi che cazzo cosa è
uscito da lì io veramente smetto di
commentare se cose perché però vabbè
lasciamo perdere
c'è un'altra cosa che luccica qui
e caduto si vabbè comunque c'è un'altra
chiave qui si perfetto che cazzo e
chiave della stanza della sorveglianza
si scommetto che il sorvegliante non c'è
proprio sto presentimento c'è
l'ascensore che non funziona ho capito
cosa devo fare ho capito allora
praticamente io devo ritornare devo
ritornare nella stanza di sotto che
prima era chiusa accendere i motori per
l'ascensore credo e poi tornare qui
sopra però dato che ci metto un ora
faccio che tagliare direttamente perché
sennò vi annoiate vip prima che arrivo
lì sotto ci metto due ore quindi raga
faccio che tagliare
ma che cazzo
non l'avevo visto merda si stava
mangiando i talk show ha fatto ha
scassato merda scassato tutto l'impianto
elettrico ma non posso più scendere
minchia fi ce la fai a scendere delle
maledette scale con un mamma mia
io le saltavo quando ero piccolo le
scale non facevano anche i gradini e tu
minchia scendi peggio di mia nonna
veramente cosa ha fatto quello lì a
parte gli scherzi ma che cazzo ha
combinato
no vabbè dai ke kazzo soltanto più
fusibile perfetto
spero di trovarne uno nella sala della
sorveglianza in modo da far ripartire
l'ascensore se non ci sono altre
sorprese ha detto che caso c'è intanto
non c'è niente non ci vado comunque non
ci vado per sicurezza tanto non c'è
niente dato che ci metterò delle ore ad
arrivare solo a quella maledetta porta
taglio finché non ci arrivo ok ci siamo
ragazzi ci siamo perfetta prete apre chi
fa che si apre a me non sta porta ma
perfetto era quella la chi è che poi non
la inserisce neanche ci apre la maniglia
tranquillamente censura bene è un ottimo
inizio
c'è la finestra aperta c'è la finestra
aperta puoi andartene
andiamocene fottitene di tutto ascensore
[ __ ] c'è la finestra aperta caputa
nas che cazzo è caduto il lampadario
si vabbè esci da esci da cui uscì
maledetto es
non vorrei che entrasse qualcosa mentre
sta tentando di uscire
anzi adesso che ci penso meglio che sono
lontano dalla finestra tanto non penso
che esca c'è dell'erba c'è dell'erba
all'interno della fabbrica perfetta che
cazzo ste cose che cadono c'è anche
un'altra finestra ho paura ho paura ad
andare a prendere quella cosa lì ho
paura
allora se cade un altro lampadario ti
giuro che sfondo il soffitto a perfetto
ho trovato il fusibile di ricambio
l'interruttore nella corrente perfetto
ok c'è qualcos'altro dice la batteria ok
lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo
intanto lì c'è qualcosa raga intanto
dice qualcosa tipo una batteria
devo aspettarmi che cada no infatti
stavolta non è caduto
vabbè andiamocene via da sto cazzo di
posto immediatamente immediatamente
immediatamente
bene vai vai vai vai vai vai fuori dalle
balle fuori
usciamo di qua raga devo torna di nuovo
adesso devo andare a rimpiazzare il che
poi non è un fusibile ma un interruttore
rotto cielo rimpiazzo con quello rotto e
poi niente l'ascensore dovrebbe
ripartire quindi siamo a posto
taglio di nuovo finché non è pronto
pizza sia una volta formaggi è una
margherita si ok perfetto casa successo
ai agli spasmi ti sei spaventato per una
chiamata quando c'è un bambino che
continua girati attorno da ore vabbè
comunque
continuiamo ragazze non ci sono sorprese
taglio fino a che non arrivo lì ok
ragazzi siamo allora rimpiazziamo
perfetto
ok perfetto ho sentito anche l'ascensore
che è tornata in funzione
quindi non dobbiamo fare altro che
tornare lì su ok raga dopo due ore di
incessante camminata siamo arrivati
siamo arrivati siamo arrivati è anche
aperto tra l'altro l'ascensore ci siamo
ragazzi siamo non vada non vorrei mai
andare gli assi cristo no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no merda a me dopo
indietro ma indietro indietro corri
maledetto idiota con ricordi darmi i
carri
[Musica]
via via via via via via via via via via
via via via cazzo cazzo cosa sta facendo
porca [ __ ] no no no no no no no sono
venuto a utah giusto torna indietro
ok ok ok ok
piano piano c'è adesso il soffitto di
nuovo integro ma che cazzo sul set
perfetto siamo entrati via via di qua di
art
clicca qualcosa chiudi ti fa che si
chiuda fa che si che da fare si chiesa
ove già auguri come da posto guerra cosa
mi hai fatto passare lurido stronzo di
un cane però va bene un panino lei ti
perdono
cazzo si è bloccato la seco sapevo lo
sapevo
nei giochi ora va sempre a finire così
merda merda merda merda merda merda
merda cazzo no
dove vai pupino no è morto fuffi e morto
è morto fu attaccato il cane tutti
coloro che varcano la sua soglia sono
condannati è nata una nuova maledizione
è tua sorella è nata
vabbè comunque sicuramente se un fifone
domandato finire ospito vinto rosso
tipico dell'ariete
ma è falso
vabbè raga dopo questa lode di coraggio
che mi ha gentilmente fornito il gioco
guardate il livello di vigliaccheria
fantastico
va beh a parte tutto questo direi che
posso concludere qui per mia fortuna
all'episodio se vi è piaciuto il video
come al solito lasciato un commento
è un mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come al solito trovate nella
descrizione di ogni mio video sono siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi ci vediamo
un prossimo video ricordatevi che
comunque domani esce il primo episodio
di scribe l'ulss unlimited quindi non
perdetevela è niente ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]